all right let's jump right in um a lot
of today's show is going to be
essentially getting ourselves caught up
and framed in terms of the state of the
republican party right now and
while some of you may think this this
has everything to do with trump it
doesn't it has some to do with trump and
it has a lot to do
with some of the developing factions in
the republican party but also just the
fundamental
kind of empirical problems that need to
be solved before
if and before the republican party would
be able to participate in any meaningful
political policy and scientific
discussion and
th this i may be sort of not clear in
what i'm talking about but to begin with
let's start with part of the problem
with scientific framing in the
republican party we have a new poll out
now from economist yougov
which shows that republicans
trust on medical issues
donald trump over dr anthony fauci
over the cdc and maybe not surprisingly
over the biden administration that one
maybe would be to be expected
but um less indicative of a problem
than is the lack of trust in dr fauci
and the cdc the vast majority
of republicans surveyed say they trust
donald trump on medical advice despite
the fact that he wondered about
injecting bleach disinfectants
etc 66
of self-identified republicans say they
trust
trump a lot or somewhat for medical
advice
only 11 percent of republicans trust joe
biden now
that's less of an obvious problem to me
in the sense that
they're both politicians now of course
you and i would look at that and say
well but joe biden's positions are just
repeating what doctors say whereas
trumps have been arguing against doctors
no doubt about it but it's less
concerning
than when you compare to dr fauci and
the cdc
um you look at uh 20 the cdc had the
highest level of trust at 57
overall uh dr anthony fauci had 48
percent trust
overall but when you look specifically
at republicans republicans trust trump
more than fouchy
and also more than the cdc so
why do i care about this it's not
because i want to go and
make fun of trumpists who trust trump
over dr fauci i really don't care
many of them believe lots of things that
aren't true and it
doesn't really matter in terms of the
political discourse or in making
specific things happen they just have
different beliefs and we just sort of
write it off
here it has a very practical life and
death implication when you
think back to the start of the pandemic
and you look at the disastrous u.s
response
much of what we see today is as a result
of that when donald trump and
republicans
i don't know if pretended or lied or
whatever didn't know
all along how serious this was and
the masked discussion where they were
against masks
and the guidelines discussion where they
were against guidelines the open
everything people
and then of course as we got into the
vaccine era if for a year you've been
told this isn't really serious and you
don't need to do anything of course
you're going to be less likely to want a
vaccine why would you need a vaccine for
something you've been told for a year
isn't serious anyway and then the
conspiracies and then the bill gates
rfid chip vaccinations or whatever the
case may be
this has very real world implications
and when you now look at the numbers and
you look at
uh i mean could there be more
dramatically different vaccine
situations than for example mississippi
and massachusetts to pick two states
that start with the letter m
uh widely reporting in mississippi
tens of thousands of vaccination
appointments that no one's showing up to
they're trying to figure out in
mississippi what do we do because we
have all these locations we have all
these appointments available we have all
this vaccine
and people aren't signing up compared to
a state like massachusetts
where 92 of the population
says that they want the vaccine
massachusetts reportedly 30 days away
from herd immunity very different
situation in mississippi while it's warm
or warming while we are seeing a decline
of cases
okay maybe you're not going to see
dramatically different situations
when if indeed this becomes seasonal and
we start to see another uptick in the
fall
you're going to see another two-tiered
system from states with herd immunity
and states that completely lack it so
when when you see a poll
and it says these republicans trust
trump
more than fouchy or the cdc it is easy
to just laugh it off and say look at
these stupid people
but it affects everybody uh as we know
not everybody can get vaccinated
children won't be able to get vaccinated
for some time we still don't know how
long hopefully 12 to 16
and 12 to 18 very soon you know 8 to 12
is going to take longer etc
this has a real world impact and when
you
when you trust trump over fauci it
follows perfectly logically
that republicans would be trump
supporting republicans would be
the most anti-vaccine group in the
united states at this point in time how
do you change this i don't know
we have seen the anti-vac sentiment
decline
the number of people who want the
vaccine has gone up
one idea from from a couple of weeks ago
was
maybe if there are more uh pastors
and clergy that are saying get the
vaccine as a religious duty
uh the vaccine you know p buddha judge
saying over the weekend
um uh god allowed the vaccine the
vaccine exists in the context of god
imagine god you know if the vaccine was
really bad god would have prevented it
or something like that
makes no sense to me based on my
sensibilities maybe that would work
in uh at least getting more religious
republicans to be interested in the
vaccine i don't know what the answer is
but the point is
the this has real world impact we talk
sometimes about flat earth as a
relatively benign conspiracy theory
you can make the case with flat earth
that often flat earthers believe lots of
other stuff that is damaging you've got
a lot of overlap between flat earthers
and um uh other types of conspiracy
theorists anti-anti-semitic conspiracy
theorists
um you know one world government type
stuff
by itself flat earth as a belief is not
damaging in the same way that the
false beliefs about the pandemic are
and we're seeing that translate in very
real terms these people trust trump over
fouchy
and they are one of the most
anti-vaccine groups how do we fix it i
don't know
what i do know big picture is that
placating the anti-vaxx beliefs is not
the way forward
and speaking of placating and
negotiating with terrorists
we have to talk next about joe manchin
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and thankfully
there's a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video